success making people soft I spoke to
David Goggins about it on the podcast
you know he's this guy who can command
millions of dollars for speaking gigs
and he's choosing to go smoke jumping
have you seen this thing that he's doing
so smoke jumping is when there's a
wildfire in the middle of nowhere and
they need to air drop in the
firefighters so they parachute in with a
pack around their waist and they also
put huge water bucket things that
they'll attach their hoses to separately
parachute them in and they just live in
the fire until they put it out sometimes
they're out there for a week pretty sure
he makes it's either 7 or 12 an hour
instead of going and doing this speaking
to it and I asked him about success
making you soft he says I see it way too
much and that's why I don't like it I'm
not about the flash I'm not about any of
that